foreign
what we talking about why do we cling to
junk eventually even your trophies
become garbage take a look at this video
with Mike Tyson
stuff this is history here
you are your history this is garbage I
could say I bless the garbage at one
time it meant a lot when you're just a
young kid this is everything to you but
then you realize your priorities change
and you just want your children to be
happy and do nice things and that makes
you happy this is nothing
oh TK
first off several people sent me this
video Danny sent it to me the Nicodemus
as usual send it to me three days later
after the whole internet had seen it he
finally latched on to it
and he sent it to me from some Reddit
post
or slash conspiracy
nice TK's Reddit the thread that he
likes it's his subreddit but let's talk
about this
the things that become our trophies
and we're so proud of
if you're just listening to the audio
version of the podcast by the way we
watched a video of Mike Tyson looking at
a table of his old gloves and and
championship belts and trophies and he
starts flipping it over and saying No
this is garbage
so our awards that seem so precious to
us in the moment because they
commemorate a precious moment
they turn into garbage when we just
cling to the trophies the awards the
successes the status symbols because we
realize that is not the championship
it's just a representation of something
I did in the past
I'm sure there's some young boxer
somewhere
training hoping dreaming to acquire all
that same garbage
I'm curious do you believe there are
some forms of garbage we can only
recognize as such when we procure them
yeah that's a great question remember
the second time we had Jeanette McCurdy
on the podcast she was finishing writing
her book
which is called I'm glad my mom died
and she's like I'm just so afraid it's
going to be trash
and I said well it is
like well yeah but like I mean like the
finished product is gonna be trash yeah
it will be
what do I mean by that
what I meant is that
a it will be trash to someone like
someone's not going to like it and
that's not a compelling reason for me to
not write a book
if I am writing a book so that everyone
will like it I will never write a book
but also it will be trash in the sense
that to you eventually you're going to
be like oh yeah it's a neat thing I did
but
it doesn't really matter that much to me
anymore
the things I enjoy right now will be
trash tomorrow the food that I eat
produces some sort of trash waste right
trash isn't a bad thing it just means
that something that we use has now gone
to waste
and that's okay
but when we cling to it what what Mike
Tyson was doing there is he was saying
I'm not clinging to this anymore that's
who I was it's not who I'm going to be
in order for me to be the person I want
to be I have to let go of the past
yeah and you know wisdom is a funny
thing it can be the same wisdom can
dwell in two different people for
entirely do two different reasons uh for
entirely entirely different paths you
know I imagine that the reason he's able
to look at that and say it's trash is
because when he was pursuing it he was
chasing something and those trophies are
represented the best instantiation of
what it was he was really after and once
he had it he realized wait
there's a hunger in me that is still not
satisfied oh it's the hunger for a
deeper kind of legacy to have children
to cultivate good human beings to see
them prosper and do well in the world
that's really what I'm after and so we
all have these different things that
symbolize for us that Z good that that
ultimate end and sometimes in the
chasing after those things if we're
lucky enough to acquire them then we're
blessed with the opportunity to see that
it's deeper than that and maybe
sometimes the tragedy of not getting
what you want is that maybe you never
get the chance to see
how lacking it is and its ability to
truly satisfy you
yeah I had to get everything
I thought I wanted to realize that
everything I wanted wasn't actually what
I wanted
those things can be a nice byproduct
nothing wrong with owning a Lexus it's a
fine piece of engineering right
but the Lexus is not the point of living
and one other thing
the beautiful thing about wisdom is that
it is not
it does not belong to the privileged
however you define privilege
you know there's a there's a proverb
that speaks of wisdom as the voice of a
woman who says she cries out to people
when they're in the marketplace hear me
listen to me spend time with me every
single day wisdom is calling us while
we're chasing those things whether we
get them or not wisdom doesn't say I'll
reveal my truth to you I will give you
my insights when you get everything you
want and you see that it can't satisfy
wisdom is calling out to us even as
we're chasing those things and it's
saying just take a break
and hear me out and maybe I'll
contextualize your chasing in such a way
so that you begin to pursue different
things or you find a deeper kind of rest
that isn't found in the chasing after
things I don't have time for wisdom I'm
headed to the Gucci store
shout out to Mike Tyson um I really
enjoy listening to him on this podcast
it's really I grew up in the Mike Tyson
uh golden age of boxing where I watched
him emerged and become that youngest
champion and I just watched his whole
journey and it's just so interesting to
see him continuing to deepen his
Reflections on life and the way he is
honest about all of his challenges and
his failures and the way he wrestles
with things he's a man that never claims
to be or pretends to be perfect and just
uh it's just interesting watching Mike
Tyson after growing up watching him in
the ring seeing what he's doing outside
the ring in order to grow he had to let
go of those past accomplishments but
because he realized that once you've
reached that Peak that Pinnacle that
Apex of life if you keep staring at it
you're not gonna get anywhere from there
and also I think quite often what
happens is that has happened with me a
lot is it's also taking time to pause at
the top of the mountain there and saying
oh yeah
you can acknowledge us and the trophy is
a byproduct of this but it is not the
point I didn't do this simply for the
trophy did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free